I'm Keen to get to your vision yeah to
what you would do if you were the next
prime minister but first I just want
your reaction to the Westminster
accounts project whatever your views on
you know political donations or outside
earnings surely more transparency has
got to be a good thing transparency is a
good thing I think that you've obviously
pulled together a lot of information
there made it publicly available I think
it was all in the public domain because
it's all been declared according to
we've got strong rules as you know I
think we've got some of the strongest
rules in terms of what we have to
declare but you know the more
transparency the better so everybody can
see exactly what has been declared and
ask whatever questions they want to
about it yeah and I think it's the
accessibility I mean you can pull up
whoever you want you know your own entry
I guess you think it's important for
your own top team to be transparent as
well yes I mean I think uh it's fair to
say that everybody is declaring in
accordance with the rules that been in
place for some time what you've done is
bring that all together in one place but
um it's all been declared according to
the rules absolutely right um I think
the thing that's interesting about the
project for me anyway is that you can
have a comparison as well so you know
what's usual in terms of earnings and
what is perhaps not and it is also fair
to say that the if you're looking at the
higher standards the vast majority are
conservative and peace nearly all nearly
uh just want to have a look uh on
November the 16th 2021 you made a speech
on how to improve parliamentary
standards and you said these are the
changes that labor is calling for first
a ban on all second jobs for MPS with
very limited exceptions and then 13 days
after that speech David lamo becomes
foreign secretary you can have a look at
his entry on our database
um he's earned 106 000 pounds since the
16th of November 2021 which is when you
made the speech so how is that
compatible with your ban on second job
well Sophie what I was proposing was
um a system for all MPS that we should
ban second jobs there's a discussion
about what exemptions there should be I
think um David for example does a lot of
media work and I think media work and
writing books is all part of the
political process but there's a
discussion to be had what I was urging
was for the whole House of Commons to
agree new rules because I do think that
we should get rid of second jobs with
some exceptions some people have jobs
where they need to top up their skills
um and I do think if you write a
political book or uh you know
yeah exactly that may be grounds for an
exemption but what I wanted what I still
want is for the whole House of Commons
to agree new rules which are stricter
than the rules that we've got and as
soon as we can do that the better so you
you mentioned some exemptions and so in
your view then making 90 000 pounds from
a weekly radio show as David Lamey has
would be an exemption or how about tens
of thousands from speeches to Bankers
Consultants Tech phones as he has I
think parliament's got to come together
and decide what the exemption should be
but I for my part I think the rule
should be stricter I think but you can't
say which jobs should be banned and
which should broadly speaking I think
that
um there's a million miles of difference
between someone who's you know advising
a company on strategy for example and
someone who's writing a political book
but look I'm open to a discussion on
this I think the rule should be stricter
I would like the House of Commons to
come together again and have another go
at changing the rules obviously
um when we said those things that was in
the middle of um some terrible rule
breaking that was going on in the House
of Commons last year last year was a
busy year but look do I think the rule
should be stricter yes I do do I think
it's very good that it's transparent yes
I do do I encourage the house to come
together because in the end it's not a
party political matter it's going to be
be the whole of the House of Commons do
I want the House of Commons to come
together to have another look at it yes
and then we can have a discussion about
what the exemption should be the
narrower the better in my view but
obviously we've got to reach an
agreement go forward from there okay
thank you very much
um you want to be the next prime
minister right now for many of our
viewers the number one priority is the
health status yes what is your plan well
I think firstly we got to acknowledge
that the health services not just on its
knees it's on its face I think as we sit
here today there are 7.2 million people
on the waiting list speak to anyone who
works in the NHS and they'll tell you
just how stressed it is my wife works in
the NHS so I know this firsthand so the
NHS is on its face there are immediate
things that we have to do to get through
this winter
um but I think that bigger than that
we've got to have change and reform
we've got to make sure the NHS is
sustainable not just through this winter
but over the next 10 years and that's
why I've asked West streeting to do our
work on change and reform and I want a
10-year plan for Change and reform of
the NHS and that's what we would Usher
in as a labor government not just the
sort of what I've called the sticking
plaster politics of getting through the
winter crisis but actually fixing the
underlying problems and changing the NHS
so for example I think we need much more
preventative work we need to intervene
much more quickly and I want to see
Health accessible in our community so
there's big change and I think it's for
the labor party to do that we set up the
NHS and we will ensure the future of the
NHS but just at the moment we've got a
crisis and it's the worst crisis we've
ever had and that's because we've had 13
years of neglect and how over do you
think then the pressure currently oh if
you look I mean of course kovid put
extra pressure on the NHS nobody would
deny that certainly not me with my wife
working in one of the big London
hospitals I know what stressed that put
us under but the waiting lists were you
know 4.6 million before we went into
covid the
difficulties we've had with Workforce
has been there for a very very long time
they've never been fixed by this
government so one of the one of the
first steps we would do and we've
already set out is to get rid of the
non-dom status which allows very wealthy
people not to pay their tax in this
country we'll get rid of that and use
the money from that to double the number
of medical students coming into the NHS
so that's the first practical step well
we've got to go much further than that
change in reform is what is needed we're
going to consult on this in the course
of the coming months and then there'll
be a 10-year plan for the NHS under the
next Labor government you are doing the
thing that some people are very
frightened of doing which is talking
about private sector involvement as well
um in your speech this week you talked
about the public and private sectors
working in Partnership there's been a
move where you want to see more use of
beds in the private sector just explain
the thinking well um the immediate
problem is obviously
um the waiting lists and um one of the
uh issues that we've looked at is
whether or not uh we're using the
private sector effectively a number of
people do go as NHS patients to the
private sector
um our research shows that that's been
underused and we could do more of it and
that would clear you know 230 000 people
off the waiting units in the private
sector in the NHS under labor yes but I
mean let me be clear we're not talking
about privatizing the NHS we're used
we're talking about using the private
sector effectively
um and free at the point of use is an
absolutely governing Principle as we go
into this review but we do need change
and reform I want to look for example at
Primary Care would it be possible to use
local pharmacies more to do work on
prescriptions Etc is there a route for
self-referral what do we do about
um you know the Partnerships of GPS
which I don't think are necessary as
efficient as they should be we're asking
all the questions questions that are a
bold incoming government should ask
about change and reform now we want to
consult because obviously
with the doctors unions that it sounds
like this could could provoke you're
willing to have that battle yeah we've
got to have battles I mean I ran a
public service the crown prosecution
service for five years in part as part
of the criminal justice system and I've
reformed that and my experience of
Reform is there will always be people
who say I wouldn't do that I'd keep it
as it is uh don't touch anything I
totally uh you know disregard that I
think we've got if there's change to be
made we've got to get on and make it so
this isn't a battle with a particular
sector but it is a statement of intent
we need to change we need to reform we
need to make sure the NHS can survive
for decades to come and that will mean
change in reform and we're not going to
pat down the first time somebody says
well I wouldn't do that I wouldn't
change this I just want to have a look
at one of your 10 pledgers during your
leadership campaign to become uh the
lead the labor party and you said this
in it you said Public Services should be
in public hands
here we go public services should be in
public hands not making profits for
shareholders and this is to keep it end
Outsourcing in our NHS so why have you
changed your mind well we're not talking
about privatizing the NFL or any public
well the NHS has always used elements
from the private sector GPS for an
example is an example your pledge you
said end Outsourcing on our NHS you've
changed your mind yeah well look the
Outsourcing of some issues and functions
I don't think has been very effective
but if you take the NHS then it's just
as always used GPS in private practice
that's always been part of it for many
many years the NHS has referred NHS
um you know patience to the private
sector to have operations hip operations
knee operations Etc I think we could be
more effective at that but I'm not
talking about privatizing the NHS the
same is true in criminal justice I do
think it should be run as a public
service but it doesn't mean there aren't
um there isn't a private sector in there
self-employed barristers for example
from the private sector provide a
service in criminal justice in relation
to prosecutions what I want to ensure
that is that our Public Service which
frankly are on their knees I mean you
know ask your I I mean you know ask
yourself the question is any public
service now better than it was 13 years
ago when this government came in and I
don't think anybody with a straight face
could answer that question and say yes
they're better than they were no nor
could anyone frankly answer the question
do you feel personally better off over
the last 13 years or is our economy
better off almost all those questions
Peg only one answer which is no you um I
was quite interested earlier in the
interview when we talk about the NHS and
you were saying about how your wife
tells you stories about what's going on
what kind of thing did she say well you
know
probably what everybody working in the
NHS so I mean my sister used to work in
the NHS my mum worked at NHS so I know a
lot about it and obviously a lot of
people we know work in the NHS but it's
completely under strain one of the big
big issues is Workforce and that's why
it's very important that we made that
commitment end on Dom status use that
money to train up the Next Generation as
well because people say pay is a big
pack yes we've got the strikes of course
as well and the leader of the Royal
College of nurses suggested this last
week that her members would accept a 10
pay rise would you would you agree to
that well look let me tell you the
approach we would take because I think
many people we know you'd get around a
table and negotiate but what kind of pay
rise let me just walk through and I'll
obviously answer your question don't
worry about that but just walk it
through
um the nurses have never ever had a
national strike before ever
they don't want to be on strike
um and it's a badge of shame that for
the government that we're even in this
situation all they're asking for is the
government to get in the room and
negotiate with them and they said that
before they're asking for more money
aren't they before the strike started
and that week before the strike started
they said if the government comes into
the room to talk to us we won't go on
strike and the government has refused to
do so
um if if we were in government we would
go in the room and discuss we would have
taken up that offer so the hypothetical
you're putting to me what would you do
if you were in government yes we would
roll up our sleeves we would go in and
we would talk to them it would resolve
this issue uh just add two other bits to
this firstly the when the nepher was a
national strike under the last Labor
government 13 years ago
today is key isn't it would you would
you agree to a 10 pay rise for nurses
there's going to have to be compromised
on both sides I'm not going to sit here
answering 100 pathetical about the
situation you're asking me what would I
do in government if I was in government
I'd go into the room and negotiate but
equally so that's what they're doing
next week because if I was in government
if I was in government I wouldn't come
on your show and say in advance of that
what percentage
um you know might be a compromise what
we would discuss anymore than the trade
Unions would so I wouldn't expect the
government to come on your show and say
this is the percentage I would expect
the government to come on your show and
say yes we'll get in the room with the
nurses and we'll bring this strike to an
end okay and now you made a big speech
this week setting out your vision for
the country what's the most important
message from it do you think that
viewers should take away oh that we need
hope and change after 13 years of
failure we need hope and change we need
a decade of national renewal and that is
what we will bring about growing the
economy restoring our public services
and making sure that people have much
more of a certain influence over the
decisions that affect them now in the
speech you appropriated the language of
brexit you said that you were the man to
Take Back Control so you said this you
said as I went around the country
campaigning for Romaine I couldn't
disagree with the basic case so many
leave voters made to me
so is that why you led the campaign for
a second referendum you said that you'd
vote remain in a second referendum and
you describe the leave vote as
catastrophic for the UK you said all
that because you just you agreed with
Lee Victory but Sophie what I said in my
speech is something I've said actually
many many times I've always accepted I
voted to remain I'm not going to you
know and I campaigned and then come in
for a second I I voted for Maine I I
campaigned for remain
um and second referendum we lost the
um referendum but deeper than that
um beyond the technical question should
we be in the EU or not I felt that bound
up in that referendum was a big question
about change people desperately wanted
change that's why I think Take Back
Control was such a powerful slogan in a
way it was a Heineken phrase it got
inside people and if you can't make your
household budget balance you don't feel
you've got control if you don't feel
that you can send your child to a school
that is uh excellent in your area
because there isn't the school's
excellent you don't have control if you
feel that anti-social Behavior means you
can't go out in your neighborhood after
dark you don't have control that
powerful case for change over and Beyond
the question of EU membership was always
that I've always actually accepted that
I think most people who voted remain
would accept that as well yeah but I
guess United Kingdom a lot of Voters
will say you know they they voted
leagues they want to leave the EU
I think there was more in that vote than
yesterday if you're honest do you think
you're shifting messages because the
electorate that mattered to you at then
was a pro-remain party membership would
be voting for the next labor leader the
lecture that matters to you now when
you're promising to Take Back Control
are those swing voters many of them who
voted for brexit are you changing your
message to suit your own purpose no
Sophie I've long reflected on that 2016
referendum as I've reflected on the
Scottish referendum in 2014 where you
know a large number of people voted yes
of course you know the technical
question on the ballot paper was
membership of the EU or you know
Independence in Scotland but sitting
behind that I think there was a very
powerful emotional case for change which
I don't think most remainers
um would argue with I certainly didn't
I've always argued that the other side
of Brett brexit is delivering the change
that's needed in this country well let's
talk about that's what I was setting out
my speech uh just earlier this week
let's talk about some of the changes
that people wanted immigration a big
part of the Take Back Control message
for many people and obviously a big
political issue now was small boats and
also record levels of immigration so 1.1
million people arrived in the UK in the
last year is that too low or too high
well look so if you're not going to get
into a numbers game we need Fair rules
um firmly applied and we need to
distinguish between the different
reasons that people come to this country
some people come to join their families
I think broadly speaking most people
accept that that's perfectly all right a
number comes to students now all the
best students from across the world to
come here some arrive as refugees
including from places like like
Afghanistan and Ukraine and obviously we
welcome them as we always have done and
some come to work now what I've said in
a speech I did earlier in fact at the
tail end of last year is that when it
comes to those coming to work of course
we recognize and welcome the
contribution that everybody who comes to
this country makes but what I've said to
the CBI is we need to wean ourselves off
this sense that rather than skill up and
train people in this country we can
simply bring people in from other
countries I don't think that's right I
think that we can do far better on the
skills in this country so I think
there's room for fair rules for firmly
applied and for a national debate about
what we want from immigration one of the
reasons I'm Keen to get you a view on
this is because it feels to be that you
have shifted I guess on immigration
again in in the last few years so in the
leadership campaign we can see on one
side of the screen one of your pledges
was to defend free movement as we leave
the EU of elidship pledge in 2020 and
then compare that to a melon Sunday
interview freedom of movement is a red
line for me it won't come back well
let's just look at those these are
diametrically opposed of course they're
not look defend free movement as we
leave the EU right we've left no so now
we've got to face the future we're in
we're out of the EU free movement is
gone so the question then comes well
what do you want now do you want to go
back or do you want to have a different
system with Fair rules except this is as
we leave the EU but this is this is
acknowledging that we're leaving the EU
and saying that you'll be defending free
movement as we leave but we've left
we've left and therefore free moment
free movement was part of the package
for being a member of the EU inevitably
um we've left free movement has come to
an end now for a different question
arises which is what immigration system
do you want now and I think we should
have a fair system with Fair rules that
are firmly applied and that's what we
would devise so it's nothing to do with
the fact that in the leadership campaign
you were pitching to pro-remain labor
members and now you're again looking at
those swing voters many of them who
voted brexit if you don't like my
principles I have others there's nothing
to do with that I think so here I mean
it's obvious what that pledge was as we
leave the EU we've left the EU we've got
to face the future as it is but I see
this the other thing that I said when we
did lots and lots of speeches and
hostings uh materials in that leadership
campaign my overwhelming pitch the labor
party was we have to win the next
election otherwise none of the things
we're talking about are kind of come to
pass and we've lost elections
consistently since 20 10 I'm determined
that that won't happen again and that's
why I set myself when I became leader of
this party just under three years ago
three tasks the first was to change the
labor party when you lose as badly as we
did in 2019 you don't look at the
electorate and say what were you doing
you look at your party and say we're
going to change and we've been really
clear about the change that we've
brought about within the party well
that's anti-Semitism whether that's NATO
whether that's our relationship with
business the second thing is we have to
expose the government is not fit to
govern well you can see what 13 years of
failure has done the next stage is to
lay out the alternative we began to do
that last year and 2023 is this chance
for us to set out would a bold reforming
labor government will do let's just have
a look at a picture of you this week
giving your speech if I'm a you looked
pretty relaxed and confident when you
gave the speech you know you had no
jacket you had your sleeves rolled up
you know is that the look of a man who
thinks he's going to be the next prime
minister I hope so yes um what I was
doing there was setting out
the case for 2023 for Hope for Change
and the sort of bold change double we
need a decade of national renewal and I
think
um the next election is going to be
about change and you know if anybody
asks themselves am I better off than I
was in 2010 when this government first
came in I think the answer will be no
are our Public Services any better now
than they were then the answer will be
no is our economy working better now
than it was then the answer will be no
so we desperately need change what I
want to do is to set out that case for
change not not just what the change will
be but also how we're going to bring it
now looking ahead to 2023 you can have
time to read the Prince Harry book I
don't know I haven't uh set aside time
yet are you sympathetic with him or well
my governing principle is that
politicians shouldn't Wade in to private
matters of the royal family I know some
private at the minute right well but
some politicians like the way he didn't
give opinions left right and Center I
actually don't and I think it's better
not to Wade in maybe this one then it's
2023 the year that Arsenal going to win
the Premier League I really hope so
we're we're so tight at the top
um we've got to keep going it's a
fantastic Squad really good team of
players there we're in a very very good
position